Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Sono un economista,
uno storico economico
che si occupa di benessere.
E come tale,
ho pensato di cominciare
questa conversazione
dal PIL, Prodotto Interno Lordo.
Perché il PIL degli italiani
è un po' che da delle preoccupazioni:
lo guardiamo, ha smesso di crescere;
addirittura si è fermato,
è andato indietro,
e adesso non riprende.
E do un po' di prospettiva storica
a questa analisi,
perché trarrò vantaggio
dalla grande quantità di dati
che è stata elaborata
dagli storici economici
negli ultimi due, tre decenni.
Quindi per raccontare
un pochino la storia,
e avere il beneficio
di salire un po' sulla montagna
a guardare i contorni della foresta,
anziché stare solo dentro la foresta.
Allora, la domanda che mi pongo è:
è giusta tutta questa attenzione,
questa preoccupazione
che abbiamo per il PIL?
La risposta è sì, la risposta breve.
Però sono qui per dire: Sì, ma.
C'è anche un ma, che credo
che meriti un po' di attenzione.
Allora, comincio dicendo
che naturalmente noi diamo per scontato
che ci sia la crescita economica.
Ma questo è un fatto
storicamente nuovissimo:
cercherò di mostrarvi qualche numero,
ma insomma la crisi economica
è una creatura moderna.
Per milioni di anni,
l'uomo non è stato in grado di migliorare
le proprie condizioni di vita.
Non in maniera permanente,
non in maniera significativa.
Poi è successo qualcosa:
lo sanno anche i miei figli,
alla scuola media, al liceo ormai.
C'è stata quella che il Premio Nobel
per l'Economia del 2015, Angus Deaton,
ha chiamato "La grande fuga",
scrivendo questo libro bellissimo.
"Grande fuga" da che cosa?
Dalla miseria, dalla morte prematura.
Ed è una grande fuga
che, come sappiamo tutti, è cominciata
con la Rivoluzione Industriale,
in Inghilterra, alla fine dell'Ottocento.
E poi, piano piano, tutti i paesi
hanno cercato di imitare questo modello.
Vi faccio vedere, in questa diapositiva,
la grande fuga degli italiani.
Questi sono dati, stimati recentemente,
in cui abbiamo sull'asse
orizzontale il tempo -
faccio cominciare il grafico
parecchio indietro,
sarei potuto andare ancora più indietro -
per arrivare grosso modo al 17 marzo 1861,
quando è stato proclamato
il Regno d'Italia.
Nell'asse verticale metto
il Prodotto Interno Lordo, il PIL.
E quello che scopro è che queste -
ci sono state un paio di Guerre Mondiali,
noi siamo qui.
C'è una piccola -
non abbiamo ancora il PIL
del nuovo Presidente,
perché non è ancora dicembre,
quindi dobbiamo aspettare un attimo.
Quello che si vede da qui è una cosa
che è quella che dicevo poco fa:
la normalità è stata la stagnazione,
e poi c'è stato un balzo,
un grandissimo balzo straordinario.
Che quando lo guardiamo,
lo misuriamo nel metro della Storia,
è avvenuto in un tempo rapidissimo,
perché questa linea avrei potuto
portarla indietro fino ai tempi di Cesare,
e non sarebbe cambiato granché.
Quindi abbiamo, in una diapositiva,
nella nostra Storia,
un velocissimo progresso
su cui nessuno scommetteva.
Rapidissimo, velocissimo,
ma molto molto limitato nel tempo.
E poi, come vedete, c'è un preoccupante,
diciamo, accenno di decrescita.
La stessa fuga è avvenuta
in altre dimensioni del benessere:
questa è la speranza di vita alla nascita,
abbiamo lo stesso .
il tempo nell'asse orizzontale.
E abbiamo questa straordinaria
capacità degli italiani
che sono diventati il popolo
più longevo nel mondo,
secondo solo al Giappone.
Quindi un'altra bella pagina di storia.
C'è un ma, e qui inizia il [punto] .
Ma se questo non fosse -
questa è l'unica cosa che compare,
nei libri che abbiamo.
Non c'è altro: finora,
nella storiografia italiana,
manca questa riflessione:
la crescita economica
non è un processo neutrale,
non beneficia tutti, non sempre,
non nella stessa misura.
E quindi mi chiedo: cosa sappiamo?
Be', questo è un grafico
che dimostra che, se guardo
di nuovo al caso dell'Italia,
nel corso di 150 anni l'Italia è riuscita,
al netto dell'inflazione, di queste cose,
è riuscita ad aumentare il proprio reddito
di circa 12 volte, pro-capite.
Se guardo l'Italia del nord
e guardo l'Italia del sud,
ottengo numeri diversi:
al centro-nord si è cresciuti
molto di più che non al mezzogiorno.
Questo è un esempio di grande fuga
in cui alcuni sono andati
più veloci di altri.
Posso chiedere di più
agli storici economici,
e chiedere a livello di regione:
io vengo da Modena, sono molto -
non è un caso, che ci sia
questa diapositiva:
l'Emilia Romagna è la regione
che è cresciuta più rapidamente.
Capite che, per farla breve,
è una fuga selettiva:
non tutti, non sempre,
non nella stessa misura.
Si può fare molto meglio
di [così], però è difficile.
Se io voglio capire,
come analista del benessere,
a chi si distribuisce
il beneficio della crescita,
dovrei conoscere,
entrare nelle case delle persone,
viaggiare indietro nel tempo,
conoscere i redditi o le spese di tutti;
e poi cercare di seguirne l'andamento.
Questo è un problemadifficile,
perché l'ISTAT colleziona
i bilanci delle famiglie
a partire - l'ISTAT nasce nel 1926,
i primi bilanci li abbiamo per il 1968.
Quindi come si fa a ripercorrere,
a capire la nostra storia,
per un periodo in cui
non c'erano neanche i bilanci?
Si raccolgono, ed è quello
che ho fatto per 20 anni,
i bilanci delle famiglie.
Gli italiani, come tanti altri popoli,
hanno tenuto una contabilità.
In 20 anni ne ho raccolti oltre 20.000,
e vi faccio vedere che cosa viene fuori.
Questa è una storia
che dobbiamo sovrapporre
a quella, che vi ho fatto vedere,
del PIL che aumenta.
Questa è la storia della distribuzione,
della disuguaglianza del reddito.
Ho sempre il tempo nell'asse orizzontale;
ma nell asse verticale
ho un indice di Gini.
È un indice che è molto alto
quando c'è molta disuguaglianza,
e diminuisce quando c'è molta uguaglianza.
Troviamo una storia bellissima:
gli italiani sono riusciti
a fuggire dalla miseria,
e ci sono riusciti
coniugando a questa grande crescita
una capacità di condividere,
di distribuire,
perché la disuguaglianza
nel lungo periodo è diminuita;
ma vedete che qualcosa si è rotto,
qualcosa si è inceppato
intorno agli inizi degli anni '90.
Questo è un indicatore di sintesi
che ci dà comunque una pagina
di cui essere molto fieri:
una crescita di questo tipo di evidenza
la vediamo per molto
pochi paesi, nel mondo oggi.
In questo siamo pionieri,
e scriviamo una bella pagina di storia.
Possiamo fare ancora di più:
vi faccio vedere questo grafico.
È tecnico ma vale la pena
perché mi ha insegnato tantissimo.
Il grafico funziona così:
questa volta considero il periodo
dei primi 50 anni, l'Italia liberale,
e mi chiedo:
prendiamo tutte le persone
che hanno vissuto
in quell'intorno di secolo,
e nell'asse orizzontale
metto la popolazione
ordinandola dai poveracci ai ricchi.
Quindi ho: i poveri;
classe media in mezzo;
e poi i ricchi sulla destra.
Nell'asse verticale,
misuro di quanto è cresciuto il reddito
durante questi 50 anni.
La linea rossa mi dice:
guardate, in media, durante questi -
in media, ma l'italiano medio
non esiste, siamo qui per questo -
in media è cresciuta
un po' meno dell'uno percento.
Erano gli anni in cui
l'Italia non aveva ancora preso
la traiettoria della
Rivoluzione Industriale.
Il grafico cosa ci dice?
Ci dice esattamente
chi ha vinto e chi ha perso.
Chi è sopra la linea,
vuol dire che è cresciuto più della media.
Vuol dire che, in un modo o nell'altro,
è riuscito a beneficiare
della crescita economica più degli altri.
Da questo grafico impariamo che,
in questo periodo di tempo,
[per] essere molto poveri, qui a sinistra,
non è stato il migliore dei periodi:
tutti questi stavano sotto la linea rossa.
Qui è nata la classe media,
e in particolare la upper middle class,
la parte un po' più alta.
Il tempo corre: questo grafico
lo possiamo ripetere,
e l'ho fatto con tutti
questi bilanci di famiglia.
Ho una curva per l'Italia liberale,
ho un'altra curva per l'Italia fascista,
ho un'altra curva per gli anni difficili
che sono seguiti allo shock petrolifero
fino alla crisi del 1992;
e poi ho i giorni nostri.
Ora, i miei studenti li affliggo
coi dettagli, perché e percome.
Qui c'è - sono rimasti
quattro minuti, cosa devo dire?
Impariamo una cosa importantissima:
la crescita ha volti molto diversi;
la Storia non si ripete mai,
in un qualche modo;
i vincitori e i vinti
dipendono dai periodi storici;
è una pessima idea essere poveri
in questo periodo in cui viviamo noi ora.
Vedete che, qui, più si è poveri
più si è lontani dalla crescita media,
e in più siamo in terreno negativo.
Brutta idea, una classe media
che si difende, i super ricchi -
la natura e la qualità della crescita
sono molto diverse.
Quindi, la crescita di per sé
è molto importante;
ma naturalmente non basta
per trarre e avere un senso, un giudizio
della distribuzione dei benefici.
Da cui una prima considerazione
che ci dice che la crescita economica
è una cosa necessaria,
ma in nessun modo,
per nessun motivo sufficiente
per garantire il benessere di tutti,
ammesso che condividiamo,
naturalmente, questo valore.
Questo è l'ultimo grafico,
ed è bellissimo.
Ho messo sempre il tempo
nell'asse orizzontale,
poi ho fatto una cosa complicata.
Mi sono chiesto: se io prendo
la prima decade, 1861 - 1870,
qual è il paese nel mondo
che cresce più in fretta,
durante quei dieci anni?
E poi mi sono chiesto,
e qual è il paese peggiore?
E la risposta è:
il paese peggiore è la Cina,
e il paese migliore è la Nuova Zelanda.
Ho fatto questo per tutti i decenni,
quindi ho trovato -
non ci interessa niente, adesso,
sapere chi è il più bravo -
ho trovato la linea dei migliori
e la linea dei peggiori,
durante gli ultimi 150 anni.
Questo disegna un cono,
che è la grande divergenza,
è questo grande processo
di crescita diseguale del mondo,
e poi ho messo dentro la nostra italietta,
che è la linea rossa qui.
Scoprendo una cosa terribile:
l'Italia è il paese peggiore nel mondo,
durante la decade 2000 - 2010,
quanto [a] tassi di crescita
del reddito pro capite.
Questo mi lascia un secondo messaggio:
la crescita è molto importante,
perché qui stiamo dicendo
che stiamo facendo non solo male,
ma particolarmente male;
e stiamo imparando che la crescita
può poi interrompersi sul serio,
e forse alla parola crisi -
io ho usato una parola diversa qui, no?
Scusate, dov'è?
Ho usato la parola declino,
che è una cosa molto più seria!
La Venezia del Trecento è il declino.
Sono culture che spariscono.
E tornano, magari,
però dopo qualche secolo.
Mi avvio a concludere.
Bisogna avere paura, di questo declino?
Sì.
Ma - questo è Angus Deaton,
con cui ho aperto - Angus Deaton dice:
state, stiamo ragionevolmente tranquilli.
"Science really works":
la tecnologia e la scienza ci salveranno,
garantiranno che,
in una maniera o nell'altra,
supereremo anche questo.
Avremo un nuovo Giolitti,
avremo un nuovo Einaudi,
avremo - non lo so,
però la tecnologia ci salverà.
Possibile che gli italiani,
che hanno fatto così male,
non capiscano questo?
Certo che no, lo capiamo.
Eppure, siamo nella posizione
che vi ho fatto vedere poco fa.
Allora ho solo due diapositive,
per i due minuti che mi restano.
La prima è questa.
La scienza e la tecnologia
non sono fenomeni neutrali:
implicano e comportano molte tensioni,
all'interno di una società.
Ci sono settori che spariscono,
ci sono settori che esplodono.
Una società deve volere
questo cambiamento,
deve saperla gestire questa tensione.
Se le disuguaglianze aumentano troppo,
il tessuto sociale inizia a sfilacciarsi,
ci sono -
le persone vanno alle urne,
e partono dei meccanismi
che possono non rendere possibile
l'adozione della tecnologia,
anche se è lì fuori.
Una società può non riuscire
a fare questo.
"Social capabilities" è un'espressione
usata da uno studioso
che si chiama Abramowitz,
ha scritto libri bellissimi.
E adesso unisco tutti i pezzi:
per lasciarvi amareggiati, temo,
perché non c'è il lieto fine.
Allora, quando deve
funzionare - eccolo qua.
Allora, il ritratto del nostro Paese
visto nella sua intera
storia post-unitaria
è quello di un Paese
che ha smesso di crescere
per un periodo che non conoscevano,
non abbiamo mai conosciuto prima.
Sono 25 anni che il Paese è in difficoltà,
e osserviamo indicatori
come la disuguaglianza della crescita,
e la povertà, in rapido aumento.
Quando questo accade,
si hanno delle conseguenze
che non hanno più a che fare
con l'economia, ma con la società.
Iniziamo a sviluppare valori
come l'intolleranza, la chiusura,
la ricerca della rendita,
la paura che porta ad avere,
anziché competizione, chiusura.
Questi valori sono quelli
che inibiscono la social capability.
Che impediscono a una società,
alla classe dirigente, di dire:
"Il cambiamento lo dobbiamo gestire,
ma è l'unica salvezza
per continuare a crescere
e a trasmettere benessere
ai figli e alle generazioni che vengono".
No social capability,
no science, no technology.
Non riusciremo ad adottare, ad accomodare
i cambiamenti che richiede
l'innovazione scientifica.
E se non c'è social capability,
non c'è il principale motore
che ha tenuto il mondo
fuori dalla povertà fino ad oggi,
che è la tecnologia.
La mia conclusione è: crescita, va bene.
Suggerisco alla classe dirigente,
a cui apparteniamo noi tutti,
di introdurre tre altre parole,
tre altri indicatori da monitorare:
disuguaglianza;
le persone lo fanno
perché hanno un po' di allergie
a questa cosa, bene o male che sia,
ma povertà:
agli italiani, la povertà
non interessa molto.
E guardando avanti,
le tre parole con cui vi lascio,
con cui credo -
ed è ciò che cerco
di spiegare agli studenti,
e ai miei figli a cui voglio bene -
le tre parole sono: cultura;
crescita naturalmente,
ma che sia una crescita di tipo inclusivo,
perché queste disuguaglianze
non ci consentiranno
di continuare la marcia
verso il progresso.
Grazie.
(Applausi)